lemurs are primates they're like monkeys
apes and us but they're also a little
bit different lemurs deliver on on every
level they're spectacular they're smart
beautiful they have character okay few
people know what lemurs are where they
live and they're stored it's a great
adventure story element like ancestor
arose in Africa over 60 million years
ago when dinosaurs still roamed the
earth how they arrived on Madagascar is
a bit of a mystery when you think a
small population of them washed away by
a storm drifted off to sea and land it
on this extraordinary island a veritable
paradise for these lemurs there weren't
any competing animals and so the lemurs
had a chance to evolve into like over a
hundred species
the most amazing sound in Madagascar is
the call of the injury first one starts
and then the office time and that's how
you have it Baxter
these extraordinary animals singing
together this is the largest of the
lemurs and also one of the most
beautiful ring tales are perhaps the
cheekiest of the lemurs they're the
craftiest they're definitely the most
adaptable the ring-tailed lemur lives
that one of the most difficult habitats
on earth but they come in large groups
and they're spunky and wonderful animals
you know one of the things that really
interests me about lemurs is they have
female dominance female dominance
probably evolved because it ensures that
the females get the best food and they
can raise their offspring every year
mouse lemurs are the smallest of all the
primates that could fit right in your
hand and we've been studying them now
for over 10 years this is what I know
about mouse neighbors they are the only
lemur that's a predator that's really
close it's close to true that is nearly
effect
I came to Madagascar to find the greater
bamboo lemur this was an animal hadn't
been seen alive for fifty years
when I got to run off on I had a
surprise there he was alive in
Madagascar many animals are endangered
so much of the habitat is gone but these
primates are critically endangered
there's less than a couple hundred left
in the world
they're teetering on the brink of
extinction well the most glamorous lemur
by far is the sifaka this is render
elegant looking animal what's Megas
Oceanside unique is the way they dance
when they dance and follow them dancing
segue like them also like that with the
arm you film the group and the West
Coast who live in these big pine trees
and we were actually able to see them
dancing across the beach which is
extraordinary behavior that no scientist
I met the same course
this is the Creek gentle bamboo lemur
that eats nothing but bamboo from dawn
until dusk while the day active
improving the Seas of a smallest they
are indeed some of the cutest animals on
earth look at that little face that's
very sweet
lemurs are really the ultimate survivors
they've survived for 65 million years
but the question now is can they survive
us if people can be convinced to give
lemurs just half a chance then they'll
escaped extinction again and all we have
to do is provide some habitat for them
to live in lemurs are extraordinary
animals I've known it for 25 years it's
time that everyone knew how great lemurs
are
you